[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon i'm Hika downey principal
strategy analyst with the Waimakariri
district council and now called a
meeting which is the hearing of the
drafter angora town center strategy to
order
I think everyone who's attending today
in these unusual times the Hearing Panel
submitters wishing to be heard in those
listening on the livestream
today's hearing provides the opportunity
for those who submitted on the drafter
angora town center strategy in February
and early March to present their
submission to a hearing panel for of the
42 submitters have chosen to do so today
each submitter will have the time to
present their submission followed by
members of the Hearing Panel seeking in
the clarification if needed today's
hearing is not a decision-making meeting
we are joined by councillors Barnet
Williams and Ward and now call for
nomination of the chair I nominate
counsel about it I second that all in
favor please say aye aye against carried
I declare councillor Burnett as the
chair of the drafter Angora town center
strategy hearing and I now hand over the
meeting to the chair Thank You hiker and
thank you for your introductory remarks
just to welcome all the panel the staff
involved and all the submitters who are
attending today's hearing and the
hearing on the drafter in your town
center strategy is to see the context of
what we're going to be doing in the next
10 years with over there very important
rhaenyra Town Center in our district it
acknowledges that the town center is the
focal point of ronnie aura and it looks
towards how we can inform strategies
going forward to improve and move
forward and the times that we're facing
at the moment as heiko mentioned there
were 42 formal submissions we have for
presenting today and the purpose of the
hearing is really to make sure that we
can hear from those people who wanted to
expand on the points made in their
written submission the panel has read
all of the submissions and will be going
into deliberations later on and we will
look at all of the strategy in light of
the submissions that have been made
and this will lead to a revised strategy
to be presented to Council later in the
year so I would now like to call the
first submitter for today which is Fiona
van putt again from regenerative
business development
welcome Fiona can you hear me right
Fiona if you'd like to take your button
off mute there we go just a couple of
housekeeping matters before we start
this is our first ever online hearing so
we are the trial for the rest of the
ones that we're going to have in public
meetings going forward so welcome to
this first hearing just to note that
you'll have ten minutes to speak to the
panel and then they may wish to ask you
some questions to clarify at the points
in your and presentation today remember
we have read your submissions so there's
no need to read it in full but we
welcome that you would if you'd like to
highlight some of the points that you
would particularly like us to understand
and we're particularly interested in the
outcomes that you're seeking for the
Wrangler town center strategy so you'll
have ten minutes and I welcome you to
speak now okay your honor go do it there
are some wonderful ideas and direction
of the town planning strategy but one
observation I have is that it's based on
the premise that we can take our current
economic expectations around infinite
growth and ever-increasing consumption
of energy and materials and we can
project that into the future without
consideration of the imminent climatic
economic and resource availability
challenges they were going to need to
face in the future and over 19 is
already highlighted a number of their
vulnerabilities they were already there
in the full implications of the of this
initial crisis it's totally realized of
course so the initial or the question is
how can we build resilience into the
Town Center planning now look to ensure
a long-term sustainable and positive
future for regular and to answer this
I'd like to comment on three key areas
namely residence
housing mobility in developing the local
economy
so for residential housing I feel we
need to go further in facilitating
centrally located smaller denser housing
to meet expected housing demand
predictions and in the long term I feel
it's necessary to consider restricting
further growth to the town boundaries so
it's typical in New Zealand for town
boundaries to expand outwards to
accommodate more and more people it's
for the most part our cities have grown
in a time period where fairly early on
personal car ownership was affordable
and accessible however growing global
populations in the negative
environmental impact around these
technologies in the realized constraints
around future resource availability mean
that the personal car whether it's an
electric vehicle or not will eventually
cease to be affordable or available to
most in this necessitates terms in
cities to evolve in such a way that all
essential activities are located within
walking distance or cycling for its
residents in creating a situation where
people will be dependent on personal
motorised transport will result in a
society that's not resilient to the
predicted future impacts and then
furthermore our current economy provides
mortgages that enable us to buy much
bigger houses than we can currently
afford and cause us to consume
considerable precious and limited
resources to create and to maintain
empower these oversized dwellings but
our ability to borrow money and be able
to pay it back only works when our
economy is growing and there are enough
untapped resources to allow future
growth to reach that allow future growth
to repay those debts and as this is not
the future that we're facing because the
economic downturn and recession is a
reality so that means we need to think
smaller think tiny houses lower cost
centrally located
housing it's crucial and creating a
positive and resilient future now
although I grew up in the region here
I've also spent many years living in
both the Netherlands in Germany where
Town Planning proceeded personal words
transport so I've lived in towns with
denser housing it's centered around the
town square where all daily needs within
walking distance in local producers
bring their produce twice a week to sell
at the local market in the centre and
during my time in both the Netherlands
and Germany I never owned a car because
it was both inconvenient there's no
reader pocket but it was also really
unnecessary and in addition to the
benefit of not needing to own a car
having smaller centrally located homes
generally means that you're having a
house that needs a higher quality
housing standard in people tend to spend
more time in local restaurants cafes
parks to meet with friends and families
which contributes to the atmosphere and
liveliness of the centre and it makes it
feasible for councils to hold monthly
festivals and entertainment for its
residents and so forth so it's a
self-perpetuating
improvement cycle with a very high
standard of living and ultimately this
lower resource use lower energy use
lower carbon emissions residential
planning concept it's great for the
local economy
it's cost-effective for its residents
who have more disposable income and it
reduces the risk associated with
potential future mortgage defaults also
improve social and mental health aspects
related to isolation and it has huge
benefits for the environment and
resource availability so small I can
definitely be better my second point is
around mobility now the center of rainy
you're a should be designed for most for
its people not for the occurs and just
want to show you this here you may have
seen this illustration cultural before
where
the areas that are dear to accommodate
cars have been removed it all that's
left for the people are the edges I
don't think that's what we want
necessary so the mobility project it
should not be about how do we
accommodate people's cars through
building parking buildings and the like
but how do we develop the center for
ease of mobility for people now living
in the Netherlands of bicycle was the
single most convenient way to get around
and living in Germany it was walking the
town plan will dictate what the most
convenient modes of ability are and is
addicted as we are to occurs even in
suggests that the world without them
when well-designed
is a very pleasant one with less noise
less pollution less unnecessary deaths
and injuries enlisted in financial
hardship now pray to that capital of
motor changing it center to a pedestrian
in your area
everyone was against it and businesses
was fearful of what that would mean for
them however the number of people
visiting the city actually increased
dramatically in businesses that were
based there experienced increases in
turnover like they've never experienced
before and there's many many more
examples like that one so you design an
area for people and people will come now
my third point is around local economy
so to maintain or any orders local
economy we need to find ways to
encourage true local businesses to
populate the town centre because while
popular franchises may provide some jobs
generally a proportion of the profits is
leaving the country or the region in an
a low-carbon future localization of
goods and services must exist in order
for a town to be both sustainable and to
be resilient in the face of climate
uncertainties and other crises so
imagine a town where the center is not
populated with chain stores there are
the same as what
found in every other town in New Zealand
so imagine how this diversity and
uniqueness would draw visitors to the
town and furthermore and expectation to
facilitate the transition to a
low-carbon future is that remote working
and working from home will become more
common for a lot of people and this is
likely to create a rise and
centrally-located collaborative working
spaces in hubs with small businesses or
individuals who are working remotely
sheer local spaces that have a common
board room video conferencing facilities
etc and this of course is a better use
of resources but it can bring people
into the centre to spend their money
there and it creates a vibrant business
community so this for thought it could
allow regular to become an innovation
hub in its own right way so that its
residents are not heading off to
Christchurch every day but can foster
the entrepreneurship locally in the
center here so my message in summary at
this point enable people to achieve
financial resilience through centralized
small housing options second is to
design the town for people not cars
facilitating mobility not personal
vehicles and the food is really about
fostering a true local economy which
creates a point of difference that's all
I have to say sorry any questions
Thank You Fiona for your submission that
was very well thought out and very well
presented thank you questions from the
panel councillor Williams there Fiona's
um thanks very much for your
presentation and I've got one wee
concern of you was overseas and you saw
here everybody moved around the local
towns here were they transporting their
groceries in the articles they buy from
the shops
to become forwards from the big shopping
trolleys these days are quite large and
some of you've got a couple of kitties
and they've got a pram near here where
they experience the traveling and moving
of the groceries and what-have-you who
over seas yeah well people tend to live
differently so where we lived in Germany
we had a small apartment 70 square
meters we had basically a fridge the
size of a bar fridge we had you know
just a little tiny little freezer with
in that fridge so and we had a small
kitchen we didn't have the large pantry
so we didn't have a lot of space to
store food but the supermarket was a
stone's throw away so what you would
tend to do on your way home from work
you don't go to the supermarket you buy
what you need for that day you've always
got fresh things on hand and of course
you have the markets twice a week so you
buy things that will last a couple of
days but you tend to live in a different
way and of course New Zealand similar to
America in Australia we've we've evolved
in a different way and we live in a
different way where we have these
vehicles in large supermarkets there to
further out of town and we tend to just
stock up and we have four big houses and
things like that but ultimately it's not
such a sustainable way of living in that
it's very resource hungry and if you
look at the numbers around just energy
usage alone per capita and countries
like New Zealand Australia and the US we
consume considerably more energy than
any other country including most of the
countries in Europe because of this
lifestyle that we have and so these
aren't sort of things that we can change
overnight
but the things that if we we slowly need
to change the way we do things so that
we have the sustainability and
resilience going forward thank you for
the questions
um councillor Ward thank you
given that we're a rural population and
where we don't have the volume of people
living in regular and the town's how do
you see that what you're suggesting
weekend
I think it's it's not bit just similar
to a lot of towns in Germany for example
so I returned from Germany two years ago
and we were living in a town that was on
the outskirts of the large town so and
with struck out struck out has a million
people and we were on in a small town on
the outskirts of there but the small
towns in so drunk area Christchurch for
a similar situation and the small towns
still have everything they need within
them and yes some people may still need
to commute to the bigger cities and
that's where public transport and and
things like that come in but once you
get over a certain population limit and
we're nearly at that limit and regular
now so when you get to about 30,000
you're pretty much self contained in
that you have most things here in the
advantage that around your heads over a
lot of other towns in New Zealand so I
was living in Blenheim for a while very
similar size but Blenheim doesn't have
the resources that were on yata has
because you're so close to christchurch
and because of the farming community
there's a lot of businesses here to
server that service that wider community
and so we have a huge amount of
resources so I think there are plenty of
examples of similar size that that this
can work and you know being not too far
away from a large hub has advantages as
well okay thank you any of the questions
councillor
no I'm fine thank you a really good
presentation and thank you for your
efforts
Thank You Fiona just a couple of
questions from me before we let you go
and you've talked about 20 houses and
reducing the size of houses in the town
centre and just wondering what sort of
social issues do you see that could
create and in the current climate of New
Zealand we we are used to having those
larger houses and and we're also looking
at more of a village atmosphere rather
than a high-rise type area for Amira
yeah um hi ray
it's it's not realistic for New Zealand
avila obviously but that doesn't have to
be part of the denser housing situation
anyway so for example the town I lived
in Germany that was a medieval town so
there was nothing over four storeys high
in that centre and so you generally had
one apartment per level and you know
these buildings are 500 years old and
but they've all been built in such a way
that you don't feel like you're staring
into your neighbors windows you know
there's a lot of trees it's a lot of
greenery it's really about sensible and
really clever design and there's a lot
of things that can be done that create
that positive atmosphere I mean we
naturally imagine apartment buildings
and in a lot of concrete and those type
of things but there's plenty of examples
where the living is actually very
pleasant and very positive and there's a
lot of greenery and you don't feel like
you're living on top of each other and
that's done with that you know making
sure there's lots of common areas and
there's lots of parks within that area
as well so people can come out and
congregate in those areas but also a lot
of pedestrian type areas where you're
removing some of that road space and
that's becoming spaces for people so
it's really about clever design and of
course you have to get it right because
if you don't get it right then it
doesn't work but if you get the design
right then people will come and people
want to live there so it's all about
creating something that works and the
second question was just your point
about the the chain stores all the
stores that are nationwide wouldn't
facilitating some of those chain stores
to come into North Canterbury
prevent people traveling into
Christchurch abut through they have you
have got any thoughts on that yeah I
mean I think that are always going to be
here thank you
not necessarily I mean there's a couple
of examples in and UCL and so Rifton and
I think a birthed I cook away where you
know the chain stores aren't interested
in
most it may have really interesting
stores and really interesting things to
visit and visitors love it in the
population in the in the summer holidays
and those places goes crazy because
people want to see something different
so I think there's a balance but I think
if you if you're thinking about that
seem to place where people are walking
in their dining in these restaurants you
kind of want to reserve those areas for
that really interesting stuff I mean the
the big chain stores which maybe you
have a need for some of those they can
have the the lower-cost areas or the
less interesting areas and in a hub on
the site but it would be really nice to
think that you could walk down the main
street of runnier
and see things that you're not going to
see anywhere else in New Zealand you can
imagine that would make it a really
exciting place to come and you can
imagine a visit us in the weekend coming
from Christchurch to visit around you or
because they can get things here and see
things here that they just can't get in
Christchurch hmm thank you that you've
answered that very fully Fionna and so I
think if there's no more questions we
will be able to let you go just the
steps from here the penner will take all
the information you've given us and put
it into the consideration at the
deliberations we have we're not quite
sure when that's going to be because
it's not quite business as usual at the
moment and but we will be looking at
having a meeting with the panel and then
that gets recommended to council later
on in the year for adoption of the new
revised strategy so I really thank you
for taking the time to come and see us
and we always appreciate it and you've
lived us some very interesting thoughts
so thank you again okay thanks for your
time right we've had Fiona that was
first submission the second submitter
we've got is Roseann McGee
welcome Rosen can you hear us
hi yes I can
are you going to be just doing using the
audio or will you be using the video as
well
oh so yes I'll just uh it's I will just
be doing audio if that's okay
that's absolutely fine thank you very
much for attending the submission I'm
Kirsten Bernhard I'm the chair we've got
Joan Ward and Paul Williams on the panel
here today plus some staff support as
well with we're here to hear extra
information from your submission on the
main points of what you'd like to let us
know today you'll have up to 10 minutes
to speak and then the panel would like
to ask you some questions perhaps to
clarify a few points we have read your
submissions so there's no need to read
it in full but we're looking forward to
hearing from you please feel free hi
thanks everyone my name is Roshan just
to introduce myself and it's okay
yeah Roshan and I just wanted to say
thank you very much the opportunity to
make my submission and also thank you
very much to Fiona
I hadn't I read her submission before I
started but I really enjoyed listening
to what she had to say and I think what
I should say for a start is that my
comments will be made in addition to
Fiona's because fiona has really covered
a lot of the subject the substantive you
know what I wanted to say you know a lot
a lot of it Fiona has covered and she's
covered it very well so I won't repeat
what she said so I'd just like to add a
couple of points to to what Fiona said I
just like to add a note first on the
economic importance of cyclists I think
what often gets missed from this
conversation it's obvious that a city or
a town centre that has more cyclists has
fewer cars and fewer cars most people
would agree would adds adds to the you
know this would have been [ __ ] the
town environment because there are fewer
cars fewer emissions
better air quality and it's just a nicer
environment safe environment the
families and so on and so forth
but I think quite often people miss the
fact that cyclists actually spend three
times more than drivers on average they
spend less per visit
but because they make more visits they
end up spending a lot more not only do
they make more visits but they're
actually more loyal as customers and I
guess you could see ur eyes out that is
I don't know but that's definitely
something that's worth bearing in mind
particularly with the town center like
run yours where after the earthquakes a
lot of the businesses have struggled the
you know the the sort of foot traffic is
reduced and people have started moving
out into into this sort of service
corridor along Flaxton Road I'd also
like to pick up on a central theme of a
lot of the submissions which is a
request for more communal spaces I know
a lot of people have different ideas
about what those spaces should be and
where they should be but if those spaces
are next to busy roads full of cars
there's just no way that people enjoy
them to their full potential people
don't want to sit outside cafes despite
the lovely weather that we have here if
the if that road isn't if they're next
to a busy road with cars hurtling up and
down it and actually the speed limit
doesn't really matter it's the cars
themselves it's the emissions and the
noise that the cars produce that put
people off from sitting outside cafes
playing in playgrounds taking the
children walking just even just going
for a walk up and down the high street
and then just lastly I'd like to add a
few notes about my experience as a
cyclist that lives just outside rani Ora
and I'm a mum I've got two small
children there two and three and I bike
everywhere with them in there in a bike
trailer we do our shopping we go to the
library I pull the books and the trailer
and the whatever you do in the town
centre if you guys don't plan real space
for cyclists along the main routes in an
hour
lots of rain Yura you're missing out on
a massive opportunity the space I live
in a hooker and it takes me just under
half an hour to get into runnier to go
to the library all the play center
whatever it is I'm going to it takes me
26 minutes to get to koi and actually
it's only just over half an hour to get
from running over to koi and I think as
the Y mat region grows and there are
more people moving out not just to the
town centers like coin run euro but also
the little satellite and satellite
settlements if you like around those
town centres there needs to be planning
so that there is space for cyclists on
those roads
I mean I've biked all over the place I
used to race on my bike and I'm a very
different cyclists to a lot of people
and I accept that and I understand that
I might cycle where other people maybe
wouldn't but these roads the road for to
go from Hoecker in Turangi hora is the
most dangerous bike ride I have ever
done and it's every time I do it it is
incredibly dangerous it's dangerous
partly because there are stretches where
there aren't there isn't any space for
bikes but I'd say it was 50% that maybe
30% that and 70% the attitudes of
drivers on the roads people don't expect
cyclists they don't make space for
cyclists on the roads and they actually
drive as if you are something to be
chased off the road I've been clipped by
enormous
trucks and lorries with two toddlers in
my trailer there's no question that
everybody knows what is in my little
trailer with a friendly waving flag but
people just don't care and that's one of
the reasons why making cycling an
integral part of the town centre and run
your is so important because if you make
space for cyclists and show people that
it's they're an important part of
society that it's a great way to get
around you I feel very confident that
people's attitudes would change because
more people would do it and the other
point that flows on from that is that
when you are planning for bicycle
journeys
it's really important to plan for those
journeys to be along main routes it is
no good to plan around main routes for
cyclists to go around because if it's
going to take you a long time to get
somewhere you're less the longer it is
it takes you to get somewhere the less
likely you are to use that form of
transport so it has to be the most
direct route and you have to plan for
real journeys to be taken by bicycle so
I completely agree with the councillors
who asked questions around the
practicality of using bikes or bikes are
incredibly practical you can attach a
trailer you can carry your kids you can
put your dog in the trailer you can put
anything you want in there and you can
put your kids on bikes seats so you can
any journey that you make in a car you
can make by bicycle and I do I do my
shopping that you know I do everything
but you have to plan for people to do
what they normally do by bicycle rather
than planning for a kind of utopian
vision where people are doing something
that's ideal because people always want
to get somewhere as quickly as possible
by the easiest way possible and you have
to help them with that and just in
conclusion I just like to go back to the
strategies overall objective which is to
improve the quality the lifestyle
aesthetics functionality and vibrancy of
renewer
well quality what kind of quality of
life do you have if you don't have quiet
streets clean air and a safe environment
lifestyle everybody wants to be
healthier and more active and giving
people the opportunity to have a
healthier lifestyle isn't a really
important part of designing for cyclists
aesthetics car parks are ugly cars emit
foul black smoke that makes leaves black
residue on everything it's not
attractive if you go to on holiday to
Italy or go on holiday to Greece people
go to those places because they would
they would those town centres were
designed before cars came along and they
were designed for people rather than
vehicles
functionality that depends on how you
design for cyclists of course and
vibrancy well that goes back to having a
safe clean environment and once you've
got fewer cars then all of a sudden
you'll have more people on the streets
and that's where the vibrancy comes from
it's from the people that already live
there it's just giving them the
opportunity to get out and make the most
of the town and that's it completes my
submissions thank you thank you a shame
that's a very clear submission are there
questions from the panel you're getting
off quite likely thank you machine
it's good that you're cycling everywhere
I love cycling and I do appreciate your
thoughts about being dangerous on the
Main Roads and I used to live in a
hooker as well there's a little girl and
I used to bike to co-op or get the bus
to go to work and to Christchurch
you might turn right when you come off
over the bridge the drain bridge and and
get on the Passchendaele cycle way
entering you might be a bit safer for
you
that's a good question but that goes
straight back to my point about planning
for people to take the most direct route
I do know about the bike paths but the
problem is if you if either way whether
you go left or right I would spend less
time on that road but it's I still have
to go along that road and actually that
corner is extremely dangerous so it's
safer to turn left than it is to have to
cross the traffic to get onto the other
side of the road I've tried every way of
getting into run yura and to be
completely honest with you nine times
out of ten now I just cycle into
Khoikhoi because the route the route in
turquoise is that much safer but sort of
recreational bike paths for people to
buy colonic weekends are great and
there's a place for them
I think the priority should be allowing
people to make their ordinary journeys
just by bike oh thank you for your son
anyway thanks counselor Williams yeah
and thank you for your submission I'm a
wee bit concerned because ring Yura is
an aging population and the statistics
are pointing that we're going to be
young getting quite a wee bit more aged
as we go with their persons so we do
need a place for some of the young not
quite so fat older elderly people to
then bring their cars near entering Yura
what would you be some rather supporting
roads that there's no cars on whatsoever
and I'm finding it difficult to then
comprehend and taking cars off the road
just four cycles where we going to put
the other cars because with what's
happened there as there's less cars on
the road but they seem to have speed up
more and I'm just wondering whether that
so we bit more concern for some of the
cyclists as take a lot of cars away in
some of the cars seem to speed up and
could possibly exaggerate the safety
nosov and cycling what's your thoughts
on there
I mean cycling is one of the best forms
of exercise for any age it really is I
mean it just puts no pressure on your
joints it's one of the few sports that
you can do right from when you're three
or four right up until you keel over and
hey whatever it's just it's fantastic
I'm a real advocate for it for all sorts
of reasons but obviously people can do
what they want I don't I'm not about to
say to people well you can't do this so
you can't do that or get out of your car
or I don't want any cars on the roads
it's not about that at all it's about
sharing the roads and making space for
cyclists and the minute there's just no
space I mean the issue of how fast
people are going is kind of neither here
nor there the issue is that there is no
space the most dangerous part
journey into Ronnie Ora is the part
where yeah it is it is a it is a hundred
zone but it's also just that there is
just this grass and then there's
immediately this road so the people
commuting in cars and isn't a lot of the
problem doesn't come from cars by the
way it's actually trucks and that just
won't slow down and won't make space for
you but it's it's difficult for me to
say I mean I think what I'm advocating
for is just an opportunity for people to
cycle should they want to and at the
minute that just doesn't it just isn't
there there's me and there's a Colin the
grass collector he cycles around a Hoka
and that really I don't see anybody else
but I do meet lots of people lots of
mums who would like to cycle their kids
to preschool in fact it's actually
probably the majority site because I see
are older people so yes it's not about
taking the getting rid of cars it's
about recognizing that cars aren't the
future and the cyclists deserve a bit of
space on roads because of all the
benefits that cycling brings thank you a
Shane council Awards got another
question it's a question well I might
say that I think that we're actually
looking at improving the the roads down
from regular through over the screw
bridge because of the usage so we could
take your thoughts into consideration
when we're planning it thank you and
just one question from me
Roisin obviously Rainier is not a blank
slate you mentioned that it's been
designed for vehicles as a rural service
town with a previously widespread
population now becoming more centralised
and you'll point about cyclists not
using other routes I'm particularly
interested in the South Korea and the
South Park area is very narrow and we're
constrained by some of the residential
areas would you say that cyclists would
use a cycle path down there or would
they use an alternative if it still took
them to the town centre so just
just to make clear are you suggesting
that you could either have a cycle path
along the most direct route we could
have an alternative route that took you
along quieter roads yes so it would
depend on what the difference isn't time
taken on the route in in my in my
personal experience I don't know what
the researchers around this but I'm sure
it's out there and I'd be happy to find
it and send it 3t if that's helpful but
in my experience that if the disc if the
difference if there is a markedly
quieter route that is only gonna take
you five minutes more great not a
problem but if it's gonna take you ten
minutes or more longer to go on a
quieter route you're just gonna take the
most direct route it's I think it's one
of the rule it's it's a well-known
reality of Town Planning that people
will always take the most direct route
and if that goes across your beautiful
lawn that you have plant it you know
whether it cut lines of desire what
they're called yeah and the same goes
for cycling exactly the same way as
pedestrians and what's your view on
shared cycle walkways I actually think
they're great I know that every now and
then you get stories about cyclists
behaving irresponsibly on pavements or
on shared walkways where they're cycling
too fast and they hit pedestrians and
people like to make a big fuss about
that but obviously it's much less
dangerous to be hit by a bike than it is
by a car and I think that just goes down
to common courtesy in good manners I
would never ride on a pavement and it's
I think that it would be much I think
it's better to make space for bikes on
roads than it is to it cyclists to share
walkways with pedestrians just because
of the speed difference I mean on a
decent bike path cyclists can be doing
30 kilometers an hour and if you want
people to commute you should expect
people to want to get wherever they're
going as quickly as possible so I think
there is a bit of an inherent tension in
that but it depends where it is because
if it's in a town centre where people
are making small short journeys they're
probably going to be going slowly and
the traffic may well be older people
children on bikes families rather than
people making those longer commuting
distances so shared what
quais around run Europe absolutely fine
if you were going to pedestrian eyes the
high street for example if that's
something that you do you go forward
with and it's you're allowed to cycle
around that that would be fine I'm sure
because people won't be going that far
on you you could it's a reasonable
expectation for cyclists to slow down in
a town centre I would say thank you very
much for that well we'll draw that to a
close now and just to let you know what
happens from here is we'll take all that
information into consideration in our
deliberations we don't have a date for
that as yet with the change of
circumstances at the moment but
following the deliberations it will be
recommended to council with a revised
draft strategy and you are able to keep
in touch with where we're at in the
progress through our website and you'll
also have correspondents as a submitter
and we will be looking at all the
submissions not only the ones who today
but also the all the written submissions
and information that's been presented so
we hope to have a draft revised strategy
to seem to council later in the year and
so thank you very much for presenting
today apologies for your name at the
start
educational network don't weigh very
much appreciate you coming and thank you
for making taking the time to submit
thank you very much
right the next submitter on our list and
apologies for being slightly late is
Rihanna or it from hands-on limited
David hello welcome Rihanna can you hear
me yes lovely well thank you very much
and sorry for the slight delay and we're
and you can see all of us on your screen
yes I can thank you and I'm Kirsten
Bernhard I'm the chair of the hearing
and we've got council award and
councillor Williams with me today and we
are here to hear your submission now we
have read your submissions so we welcome
you to make some highlights and points
or
so just to provide us with some
information on what outcomes you'd like
to see going forward and you'll have ten
minutes up to ten minutes to speak and
then we may wish to ask you some
questions just to clarify the
information so when you're ready feel
feel free to speak yeah it will be short
and informal I own a retail store in
Randy hora and the parking is really a
problem so there is really nowhere in
central rang you're aware people can
park for more than two hours and there's
no option to extend that so we offer
courses at our store which often are two
and a half to three hours that means
halfway through the class people have to
get up go and move their car and it
really doesn't achieve anything they
take the car move it to another spot in
the same parking lot to avoid getting a
ticket so that's bad for business I have
I have definitely lost some sales and
I'm sure that the other businesses
experience the same so if we want to
attract people to Rangi hora as part of
this big expansion plan which is
fantastic but if we want to attract
people to run you order from outlying
areas or Christchurch you have to give
them an option of staying for longer
than two hours without panicking about
getting a ticket and that's my that's my
little two things with what I would like
to see out of it is it would be great if
there is some way for people to pay for
for more time you know give them the two
hours for free and then give them the
option of paying for another hour or
another two hours that way you won't
have people just parking there because
they need to leave the car somewhere and
you'll be attracting business and people
would feel comfortable coming to ring
you're going for a class or you know if
you if you want to come and support the
hairdresser here it takes
a woman say a cut and it might be some
you know other things that we have done
takes an hour and a half so if you've
driven from Christchurch you you've been
in the hair salon for an hour and a half
maybe you want to catch up with somebody
over lunch and do some shopping two
hours is not enough so if the person has
two after two hours rush to get the car
away the gift shop where she might have
wandered in and bought something the
flower shop the bakery that all of that
loses out Thank You Deanna that's a very
clear submission now the panel may want
to ask you a few questions - I have no
questions from anyone on the panel
councillor Williams yeah yes good idea
and thank you for doing a submission um
and your experience as being a business
person have we got plenty of parking and
when you're getting a park it's not a
problem it's being able to stay there
yes so you think there was plenty of
parks in there I reckon there's there is
plenty of parking I've not ever had
people complaining that I can't find
parking yeah cool
and if we put on like exactly a parking
building do you think many people would
use it if they had to pay for parking I
reckon but obviously if they not staying
longer than the free period they would
opt to use the free parking but if you
intend staying for longer than the free
period whatever that might be I would
reckon that people would would pay for
parking
unless it's ridiculously expensive I
mean you you will always get the people
as well I'm not gonna pay for parking
but you know if you if you have to
choose between paying maybe an extra two
or three dollars or five dollars or
whatever it would be versus having to
rush back I would buy a few dollars to
to leave my car somewhere where I don't
have to worry about it
okay thank you my one the one thing that
is difficult is for us who work there's
way do we bug because where I wear my
business is on Durham Street the closest
I can park to my store is about two
blocks where I can actually leave my car
for long enough yeah so if the council
hit a paid parking building would you as
a business owner pack your car and up
during the day of us in this there's an
option and it's close its close to my to
my shop yes I definitely would I
definitely would
I am also I have children at school so
my day goes something like this I would
open the shop drop the kids off go go
and open the shop and then in the
afternoon I may have to take this one to
this thing and that one to that thing so
I come and go and come and go I cannot
walk two blocks every time I just don't
have the time so I just take my chances
okay but you don't want that I would
prefer something a bit more formal where
I could I know it's okay we have evening
classes as well so sometimes you know
I'm I'm in the in and out of there from
9 o'clock to 8 o'clock at night so yeah
something a bit more structured would be
grateful workers and the same if I have
people coming to work at the shop some
of them are so petrified about this if
they work a full day they for four times
during the day they go and move their
car which I think it's just crazy
because they move it from one spot to
another spot in the same a lot it's not
achieving anything okay
councillor Ward do you have any
questions no I'm I'm I'm fine with that
I agree that we need to do something
about parking and regular and I'm
looking after the people that work in
the town and providing paid reasonable
page parking for them so they can have
access really closely to where they work
so that they can
purchases and come and go with ease so
we I think it's just we were all working
on that and it's a I would say priority
should be to make it easy for people to
come and spend money in regular the
workers can work walk a little bit or
you know my goal and my first priority
would be to to make it possible you know
I don't know if you're aware of what my
business is it's a sewing and crafts
shop so we've managed to create a bit of
a hub here in regular so we've got three
excellent stores for that kind of thing
plus fabric of society plus feather and
oak which also stocks textile something
so really people are coming more than 50
percent of the people coming to my
classes are from Christchurch so we have
that potential to get them to spend
their money here Thank You Rianna just
one quick question from me if if the
council did decide for example to put in
some three or four hour parking areas
for people who do want to spend their
half-day in the town do you think that
that would then get taken up by people
who work in the town because they'd see
it as an option to have longer person
there would always be especially if
there's no other option for them you see
any other ways we could encourage people
who work in the town centre to Park and
designated areas and we're away from
that customer related parking make it
well making it cheaper than some other
paid are you considering paid parking
it's always an option that we haven't
yet decided I wouldn't get this thing I
think you know my I am not from you so
I've lived here for four years an
awesome maybe I understand local people
a bit better than when I arrived but to
me it's never been an issue to pay I
mean really if you consider when you go
somewhere and you have to fork out let's
say five dollars for parking or ten
dollars even for parking you know it's a
fact of life get over it you know so you
you will get there will be people who
will complain to start off with but then
what choice will they have I will have
to you know get over it and suck it up
and start doing
whereas I I reckon to counter if you if
you just have certain areas where you
can park for longer certainly that would
appeal to people who need to stay longer
like workers and if you don't want the
workers to pay there you either have to
find them or give them another
alternative right thank you very much
it's been very very clear and I think
we've certainly grasped your key points
there so thank you very much for taking
the time to come and speak to us today
we really actually appreciate that it
helps us just to tease out some of that
evidence you've given and we'll put that
all now into deliberations going forward
we're not quite sure when that will be
with the changing circumstances but we
will keep you posted as to the next
steps and what will happen and later in
the year once the panel is deliberated
on all the submissions we will put this
forward to the council as a revised
strategy which the council can then
choose to debate when or adopt its going
forward but that will be later in this
year so thank you again very much for
the opportunity you've been most
appreciated that you could come so thank
you for that and we'll say goodbye to
you at this stage all right thank you
right and final submitter for the day
we've got Alastair leach here we come
hello Alastair can you hear us yes we
can see you in a very interesting
location sorry I just gotta find from a
GP phone call from a GP and I had to cut
him short
I'm just south of right thank you and
welcome to the hearing today and I'm
counselors in Barnet and we've got
councillor Williams and councillor Ward
here today and we're here to listen to
your submission and thank you for taking
the time to speak to us we've all read
your submissions so there's no need to
read it in full but we'd like you to
highlight the key points and also to
talk to us about the outcomes you would
like to see in the rang you're a town
center strategy the floor is yours
okay I don't know whether this is the
correct forum to be presenting this or
not but because I've never been involved
in anything like this before I've been
involved in the regular museum for about
seven or eight years and I'm on the wiki
and roster and it became apparent to me
quite early in the piece that that had
major flaws one of them being that
building is totally unsuitable for a
museum and the present day and age and
also that it's got an aging membership
and a lot of them are getting past
actually being capable of running it and
so sometime in the future there are
going to have to be dramatic changes the
building itself the collection is a
great risk because it's not water
touched totally there's a lack of
storage in it it's a very hard space to
display anything well and also with the
aging population at some time in the
future it's just not attracting younger
members I'm nearly seventy and I'm the
second youngest member there so you know
at some stage in the future it's
actually going to come to a grinding
halt and just over the last seven or
eight years I've been quietly looking
around during Euro to see whether
there's a bit of site for it and what
could actually be done and
so I think around the the Civic precinct
is the ideal spot and I've set there on
a Sunday afternoon and only seen two
people all afternoon and quite often
they don't even know that the museum as
their until someone's told them or come
across it by chance so it was moved over
to near the library somewhere it would
be in a way more prominent position and
would attract a lot more people and
there's also the opportunity maybe to
combine it with an art gallery
so the Citizens Advice or whatever and
yes a the funding would be a problem I
would imagine with the sports stadium
soaking up so much money but the
provincial growth fund could be
approached in maybe Lottery and I've
also had my eye on the old courthouse
for quite a number of years to see what
happens with that because that in itself
was a historic building it still
wouldn't be suitable for the museum but
it could serve as an entrance way if it
could be purchased from the private
owners and sympathetic building put out
so they left of a adjacent to the
library to accommodate the museum when
you've only got to look at the museum to
see what can be done what can be
achieved and you know renderers a very
historic town it's one of the oldest
market towns in New Zealand and to to
lose and not have the stuff on display
as I think it's an absolute tragedy and
it could actually be an attraction in
itself to the town which it really needs
yeah so pretty much I do have the
support of the museum committee but
because of their age they let the drive
in vision to really push it and do
something so I guess in a way they
me as a battering ram to try to advance
submission
you know I'm quite happy to do that but
I do need support because like I said I
don't have experience and this sort of
thing and don't know where to go or how
to go about this sort of thing so yeah
it says Thank You Alastair I mean today
really is about hearing your ideas and
your thoughts so we're not asking you to
find a solution for everything and and
in fact our questioning will be simply
to clarify your submission and we're not
making any decisions today and so we
just we don't need to editorialize on
any of that information we just need to
find out what you think and what the
people around you think and it's good to
hear that you have the support of the
museum committee as well now open it up
for to the panel for questions do I have
questions from the panel you'd like to
indicate by raising a hand everyone
looks very quiet you've obviously
obvious and Sylla Williams decides to
come in as well
yeah today thank you for submitting and
you are aware these citizens of Isis
already in the regular library Ireland I
am but I thought what combined with an
information center it would be in a more
public or easy easier to foreign
location it's tucked away right in the
back of the library and and a lot of
people don't even know that's the
because of its location so that there
could be in a more prominent spot I
think yeah and for funding of such a
proposal and here would you think and
would be a go on funding but the the
Muse and don't get me wrong I think the
museum and ringers Sam like a museum to
be quite honest these big a parade what
would there be anybody in the museum to
help some to fundraise or to get things
organized for that type of proposal and
your funding is a big
thing I'm quite aware of that and no
there's not as the short answer is I see
they're all getting most of them are
over 80 and just not up to to pushing
something like this and so it's lift to
me I guess and because I don't have
experience and that sort of thing I
really need to find somebody to help me
I thought I found somebody in John John
brains Giessen and I got quite excited
but then he signed a new two-year
contract with the Justice Department so
let's undone for two years I'm still
hunting around to find somebody to help
me with no I I just want to thank you
for all the work that you do Alastair
and and supporting the museum and we'll
just have to see whether we can come up
with something for you yes thanks very
much I've just got one one question for
you Alastair and don't take this the
wrong way but if the museum was forced
to close because of the lack of
membership the lack of funding and the
building becoming not suitable for
housing the collection what would
actually happen to the collection what
would be the process I have no idea I
don't know the answer to that I guess it
would stumble along with the few people
that would be left to to run it but I
know the museum committee took a
submission to the council last year
trying to get funding to do some
renovations to the building which were
badly needed it's just not suitable for
use as a museum there it's a run down
and they could still be repurposed as
I've said in the submission for a
meeting rooms because I am involved in a
couple of other groups and we've had
trouble getting a meeting room and the
evenings around during Europe so they
would be suitable for that purpose
all right thank you for that are there
any further questions it looks like the
pen off asks all their questions so we
will thank you very much for coming
today and taking the time to present to
us you've certainly given us something
to think about and as I said before
today's not decision making but we will
take all the evidence into deliberations
we haven't got a date for there yet
because of all the changes that are
happening at the moment but we will keep
you informed and you'll be able to see
the progress either on the website
you'll also receive emails from our
staff as to the progress of counseling
the strategy once we've done the
deliberations it will be presented to
the full council for discussion debate
in adoption later in the year so we will
let you know and again thank you very
much for your time thanks for the time
to be able to present it okay right now
that draws the end of the hearing we've
heard from four submitters today as I've
mentioned this information will go
forward into our deliberations with all
the submissions and ideas that were
presented for example on the ideas board
and the gables I know a lot of people
contributed to that plus we will be
seeking additional information from the
submissions from our staff about
questions that have been raised and once
that is the deliberations are completed
it will be sent as a revised strategy to
Council later on in this year and you're
welcome to keep viewing the progress on
the website and obviously this hearing
will also be hip public and information
from the council meetings will also be
on public available publicly as well so
thank you again to everyone for
attending and I look forward to seeing
the revised strategy later this year
thank you
[Music]
you